you know a lot of these patterns you
learned
like zero to two
yeah i think they say zero to six it's
like last trimester to about six years
old is the
bulk of the subconscious programming
which is 95 percent of your operating
system yeah yeah and they they they have
this there's this phenomenon in
psychology called ghosts
in the nursery
which mean and i'll give you an
explanation um
so let's say
there we're looking at uh 18 month old
mel robbins an 18 month old mel robbins
is sitting on the kitchen floor
and i've got the tupperware drawer open
and 18 month old mel robbins is lost
because i'm following my soul and i am
playing with the tupperware and i got
this stuff all over and i've made a big
mess and i'm just like happy as a little
clam
and then all of a sudden around the
corner like my mom comes and she's
walking around the corner and doesn't
see me and slips and like ah and just
reacts
what happens in my nervous system
is that
her frustration
with the mess
and the blow-up
and the fact that i have a disruption in
my nervous system because i'm startled
i
literally
see her her behavior
with my emotional reaction
so frustration gets encoded in me i
don't even remember it i'm 18 months old
frustration
is always
this emotional feeling in my body and
now i'm just
literally copying the behavior yeah i
saw in the adults because i have a
passenger at that point in time it's
almost correct
correct and so
because emotions rise up before your
thoughts take hold yeah
it's super important to pay attention to
your body is it a is it a twitch in the
stomach is it a clench in the you know
my husband says that when he feels kind
of his pattern of withdrawing kick in he
first feels like his chest titan
that's what he feels that's that's how
he knows one of those patterns from his
past in his subconscious that he doesn't
want as an adult is about to spin
and so if he can catch it here he can
say oh here it goes i'm about to
withdraw 5432 and i'm not going to do
that i'm going to choose something
different and so that's been wildly
helpful and it allowed me to go oh i get
it this is why it's not that i'm a [ __ ]
it's that i'm talking about the behavior
i want to change with one part of my
brain but the behavior itself is
somewhere else so i got to fight it in
the region that it's in and it's also
really important you can't just catch it
you can't just interrupt it you must
replace it with a new pattern of
behavior because patterns repeat
mm-hmm you have to reprogram yourself
an a question i have too because this is
uh something i use as an indicator um
i'll use my own personal example it's um
you know if somebody is uh to reflect on
you when he's he should have looked up
something simple and obvious just google
it whatever for me it's like i judge
lazy people so i'm like god like really
just like you're complaining about that
you haven't done anything or you you
know you're just sitting around don't
you want to do something and so i
realized too that yes of course there's
part of my childhood programming i
wasn't allowed to do those things and so
therefore in my adulthood i don't do
those things meaning like i'm not i
don't i can't be lazy it's hard for me
to be lazy i don't know how to be lazy
it's like programmed in me and so
another indicator that i use is like
what i judge i deny on some level and so
i bet that you're the kind of person
that would never ask a stupid question
you'd google it first you'd do your
homework you'd do your research and then
if you couldn't figure it out you'd you
know present the presented and be like i
did everything i couldn't find it do you
know you wouldn't just go hey you know
what's weather tomorrow you'd be like i
mean you would have looked right
probably yeah
yeah definitely
you know it's interesting it makes me
wonder
um given that it was sort of like just
drilled into your head work work work
work work
do you find it really difficult
to
even
like relax on a vacation
um
i think that in the past my vacations
were like it took a couple days to kind
of get to the
to down regulate enough to enjoy it
which is why i would never take less
than five day vacations because by the
time i came down for the three days i
was already thinking i only had two left
so like at least seven gave me like a
couple to come down i'm like oh man i
got so many days left and then you have
a couple good days and then there's
still the ramp up of knowing you need to
get going again um i'm better now
um
so but i i would say that you know it
took a long time to do something simple
like just sit on the couch and watch tv
i would always think i'd have to be
doing something maybe even just like is
it a fun show am i being entertaining am
i asking good questions is it like there
had to be a little added layer to it so
i'd say that watching tv and just
resting and letting that be enough and
be in silence especially if somebody's
there is like something that took a
little while for me to
to be able to do comfortably well one of
the things that i've uh learned recently
about myself
is that because i don't you i wouldn't
the lazy word caught my attention
and
what
i've unpacked for myself is that i
am always doing something
because like so many people
i got
the most positive attention when i was
achieving
and so i married
achievement
with being worthy of love
and i know that if i
i know that i never slowed down and i
was constantly on to the next thing
because if i wasn't up to something that
was worth talking about
it must have meant that i wasn't worth
loving
either
and it was in the doing and the
achieving that i anchored my worth
and it's only again recently that i've
really been able to
see that and pull it apart
and realize that you know the things
that i do have to be separate
from
whether or not i view myself as worthy
or lovable or
likable
that as a person based on who i am and
just my existence alone you got to
anchor it there
and let the things that you're doing
just be additive
to
you enjoying your life
how did you figure it out it was the
high five habit honestly like i like i
didn't figure it out so i was 52 years
old and it was a like a
holy [ __ ] i cannot believe for how long
i have tortured myself i have just
drilled myself um you know you asked at
the very beginning if you know what my
thoughts are on us needing seasons and
you know i live in a four season climate
i love the change of seasons and one of
the most important things
about uh winter
is that when you think about how what
winter is for it's a period where
everything falls off the trees and all
that stuff that dies and falls to the
ground becomes
what nourishes
and uh
feeds
the things that are going to grow
in the spring and without the winter and
without the freeze and without the dying
off of the growth from last year
you wouldn't have the new growth and so
i deeply believe not only
in seasons where you need to rest and
seasons where things need to die and
fall off and see seasons where things
need to you know be reborn or to grow
again anew but i think that you can
start a new one anytime you decide to
and that that's also a really amazing
aspect of kind of finally waking up and
realizing you're in control of a lot
more
than you realize that you are you can
choose what you think about it it's not
easy yeah the process is simple but it's
not easy because you're fighting against
patterns but you can make a decision to
change your life you can make a decision
to change
uh what you value you can make a
decision to change who you hang out with
you can make a decision to change what
you do for a living these are all things
within your control they don't come from
wishing about them yeah they're gonna
come from work
yeah it's kind of that day one or one
day kind of thing
and and i've thought about this because
i know you talk about this and and i
love the attitude of like just it just
make the decision
count to five the five second rule just
do it right
um which is
such a great practice
um but i i was thinking about that and
i'm also
i also do think that there's some meat
to the fact that there's stuff that
leads up to going ah i can't take it
anymore i'm making a change if an
epiphany something hits hard enough
you're over it like you just hit a
breaking point and something does change
in a moment it always changes in a
moment and it's up to you to get to that
moment
so what can we do to get to that moment
with routines practices disciplines how
do we get there because there's got to
be there's always something that leads
up to it
well um
one thing that i've learned in life
is that
your breakdowns are just gonna keep
getting bigger
until you wake the [ __ ] up and get the
lesson that the universe is sending i
mean
period
uh it took me a long time to see
that i had a
very uh
painful pattern
of being drawn to
really big personality people who were
really fun and edgy and just like wow
like a shiny object and then you know
when you're having fun with this kind of
person and you're laughing all the time
and they're really edgy and you start to
realize oh my god they're actually kind
of mean to people or they're they lie or
they do this
now all of a sudden i get scared
because i don't know how to back away
and time and time and time and time like
i can go all the way back
to
uh
friends in elementary school to uh a
babysitter that i once hired to
business uh associates back in the day
to like just there there there they are
there they are there they are there they
are and it wasn't until i had a massive
issue happened with one of them it was
super painful
that made me go holy [ __ ]
this is a pattern
this person has been showing up in your
life since you were nine years old
and you have not learned it and now
you have a very expensive and a very
messy and a very
awful situation to clean up with
somebody that you couldn't draw
boundaries with period because you were
so worried about upsetting anybody or
disappointing like you're people
pleasing and so one thing to understand
is
your life is the greatest school you're
ever going to attend and it's always
sending you messages
preach
and
i hope you're not as stubborn as i am
because it took me 41 years
to
see the lesson
about
toxic behavior that i was attracted to
and toxic behavior that i engaged in in
my own people-pleasing
and inability to draw a line and like
distance myself or end relationships
that really didn't work and i know they
don't work because i get that feeling in
my stomach and then i see myself
twisting myself in knots so as to not
upset somebody who's basically crazy
and i'm now like turning all around to
not upset the person that is you know
i'm afraid of their reaction
because they're not regulated in terms
of their emotions and so i it took me a
long time and so i want every i want you
to understand if you're listening to
this that if you're in a frustrating
situation
i want you to ask yourself number one
when in my life have i felt like this
before
and
who has made me feel like this what
situations have made me feel like this
and start listing them and when you see
one you'll see another and then another
and then another and then there's that
boss and then there's a situation
and then
you'll ask yourself
what is it that i'm doing
that is having me
show up in this situation again and so i
identified kind of the the personality
pattern that i was drawn to fun
unpredictable like oh your life of the
party like kind of like just whoo this
feels fun and this feels on edge because
i can't predict
what's going to happen because this
person's so entertaining only to realize
holy [ __ ] the same thing that drew me in
is what's scaring me now and turning me
into a massive people pleaser that makes
me go crazy and so
i
if you can identify that
then you ask yourself
what is the lesson
that life is trying to teach me
this person is being sent into my life
to teach me a lesson
and for me the lesson again back to your
original question why can't we listen to
our instincts
how many of us have started dating or
sleeping with somebody
that we knew
we knew
we knew we shouldn't have been dating or
sleeping with
and then we keep going back
even though we knew
that this is not a person that we should
be with
and we like
turn into somebody else reckoning with
our and this person is being sent into
your life for a reason because you have
a pattern that you need to break
and so when you can identify those three
things kind of when in my life have i
felt this way before what are the
circumstances or people i've been around
what am i doing that i can see
contributes to me getting into these
situations
and what is this trying to teach me
and when you can look at it that way
that's how you unpack awful situations
or confronting situations and you look
for the lesson in them and if you don't
figure out the freaking lessons you're
meant to learn in this lifetime
you're you will just keep
that's it that is it
and so you know that's one thing that i
have learned recently
um and then the other thing that i have
learned
and you know it's what i wrote about in
the high five habit is this notion that
you know there's only one person that
you spend your whole life with and it's
yourself
and i had this epiphany
uh in april of 2020 when i walked into
the bathroom one morning
and you know there's a lot of [ __ ] going
on in my life and it doesn't even matter
what the details were because i think
everybody's had that experience where
you're in a season of your life
that's just overwhelming
and you don't
feel
capable or like you have
one shred of energy left to face this
[ __ ]
and
i remember standing there in the
bathroom and i had this epiphany one
morning
where i realized oh my god there are
always two human beings in the bathroom
every morning
there's you and there's a human being in
the mirror
that's not your reflection
if you allow yourself to really look
past the body in the mirror and through
the eyes you will see
you will see a human you'll see your
soul
and that woman that's staring back at
you in the mirror she is trying
she is so beaten down by you she is so
sick of your criticism
she
needs you to wake up and start
supporting her
and to start being kinder to her
she's doing her best and kind of this
epiphany that i
was relentless
in my criticism of myself
even just 18 months ago
even having
turned my life around
built this business got our family out
of the million dollars in debt got the
liens off the house which you know they
were there six years ago the liens
from the million dollars in debt that my
husband and i were in because of the
restaurant business
and
despite the fact that i've impacted
millions of people's lives despite the
fact that i have three kids that are
okay you know they're healthy they you
know are facing their stuff they're
doing their thing they're going to
school despite the fact that i've i've
been you know married for 25 years and
we still work on it ever like despite
the fact that i got a roofer i look in
the mirror and i see a woman
that i hated
that wasn't enough that that was doing
everything wrong i was relentlessly
focused
on what wasn't working